it's the place to enjoy a book and a cup
of coffee in paris
the latin quarter is the traditional
haunt of french intellectuals
tourists love its unique flair but
during the corona lockdown
the cafes were empty and all fell quiet
around the sorbonne university
even now booksellers like natalie coulon
have but few customers here
we have political philosophy and ethics
and here are the used books
whether old or new natalie has been
stalking philosophy books for over 30
years
but her clients have been slow to return
we had to adapt to try and remain
present even when we were closed
during the first two lockdowns we
weren't allowed to open at all that was
tricky
[Music]
a block away a legend is being
dismantled
the corona crisis has claimed some high
profile names in the latin quarter
je bergen one of the biggest bookstores
in paris
has closed the doors of its flagship
shop for good
for book lovers it was an institution
i was just on my way over to buy a used
booth
it's sad that such an old establishment
is gone
this district has changed a lot there
are no more cafes
only chains like starbucks the city
should do something about it and
exercise its preemption rights
for a neighborhood that's so historical
this is a terrible development
but it's not just the corona crisis
that's led to the bookshop's demise
says historian eric also who grew up
right here by the sen he believes sky
high real estate prices have
also played a role
the latin quarter is dying is dying
partly because rents are way too high
and shopkeepers can no longer afford
them but the second crucial factor
is online sales platforms like amazon
today people shop online more
and visit bookshops less
but the quarter's smaller bookshops are
putting up a fight
natalie colon knows only true bookworms
like herself
can offer personalized book
recommendations
and here people can have a hands-on
experience
would you like a mini book too oh
sorry no worries that's what they're
there for
together with other booksellers natalie
ensured that bookstores were classed as
essential services in france as a result
they could operate pretty much as normal
during the last lockdown
next she aims to beat the big internet
platforms at their own game
we've been posting new releases on
social media
instagram and facebook and showing new
ideas and themes
we show when publishers bring out new
exam preparation titles
we're just trying to react to this
crisis as quickly as possible
natalie hopes this extra effort will
keep customers coming back
and ensure small bookshops like hers
survive
so bibliophiles can continue to enjoy a
coffee and a good book
in the latin quarter
[Music]